>> Laura: AN ALERT SECURITY
GUARD IS BEING REGARDED AS A
HERO AFTER A SECURITY OFFICER
SAID HE HEARD THE TEEN SAY HE
WAS PLANNING TO SHOOT UP THE
SCHOOL AND AUTHORITIES THEN
FOUND HANDGUNS, TWO RIFLES AND A
.90 HIGH CAPACITY MAGAZINE AT
THE TEEN’S HOME.
JOINING US FROM L.A. IS THE
ALERT SECURITY OFFICER, MARINO
CHAVEZ AND WITH ME A SPECIAL
MEMBER OF THE ARMY SPECIAL
FORCES AND NOW PRESIDENT OF THE
SECURITY STUDIES GROUP.
IT’S GREAT TO SEE YOU, MARINO,
TELL US WHAT HAPPENED.
YOU’RE BEING HAILED AS A HERO
TODAY GIVEN WHAT HAPPENED LAST
WEEK IN PARKLAND.
HOW DID YOU HAVE THE FORESIGHT
AND TELL OUR AUDIENCE WHAT
OCCURRED.
>> WELL, IT’S A FRIDAY AFTERNOON
AT EL CAMINO HIGH SCHOOL AND THE
BELL RANG AFTER LUNCH AND
WATCHING STUDENTS GO BACK TO
CLASS AND OVERHEAR A STUDENT
STATE WATCH, THERE’S GOING TO BE
A SHOOTING ON THIS CAMPUS.
SO I GOT JUST PART OF WHAT HE
HAD SAID SO THEN I WALKED UP TO
HIM AND QUESTIONED HIM AGAIN AND
SAID WHAT EXACTLY DID YOU SAY
AND HE IS DENYING HIM AND I
ESCORTED HIM TO THE OFFICE AND
CALLED THE COUNSELOR AND HE
FINALLY ADMITS IT AND SAID I
GUARANTEE THERE’LL BE A SCHOOL
SHOOTING AND SAID I’M JUST
KIDDING.
I SAID YOU CAN’T SAY THAT JUST
LIKE YOU CAN’T SAY BOMB ON A
PLANE BECAUSE YOU’LL BE ESCORTED
OFF THE PLANE.
>> Laura: RIGHT.
SO THEN AUTHORITIES WENT TO HIS
HOUSE AND FOUND ALL THE WEAPONS.
>> I TALK TO THE SHERIFF’S
DEPARTMENT AND THEY INVESTIGATED
AND TOOK HIM INTO CUSTODY AND
CHECKED THE HOME AND FOUND THE
WEAPONS.
>> Laura: WHY HAS HE NOT BEEN
IDENTIFIED.
>> BECAUSE HE’S A MINOR.
>> Laura: HE SHOULD BE CHARGED
AS AN ADULT AS A PLOT TO BLOWUP
THE SCHOOL ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
MARINO DID WHAT THE FBI DID NOT
DO WHEN THEY HAD SEEN THE
COMMENTS ON YOUTUBE AND GOT THE
TIP ON THE FBI LINE.
A SECURITY OFFICER AT THE SCHOOL
SAID WHOA, THIS IS NOT RIGHT.
>> WHY IS WHY ARMED SECURITY AT
SCHOOLS IS A GREAT IDEA.
THE ARGUMENT AGAINST IT IS
ABSURD.
THE IDEA IT DIDN’T HELP IS
CRAZY.
WHETHER THE GUY IN PARKLAND
FAILED IN HIS DUTY DOESN’T
INVALIDATE THE CONCEPT.
THERE’S A FAMOUS SAYING FROM THE
WILD WEST, GOT CREATED MEN,
SAMUEL COLT MADE THEM EQUAL WITH
THE PEACEKEEPER AND NOW THE
CRAZY ONE IS ARMED ON TOO MANY
CAMPUSES AND WE NEED TO CHANGE
THAT.
>> Laura: THE EL CAMINO IS A
SMALL SCHOOL COMPARED TO PARK
LANE, 200 STUDENTS COMPARED TO
PARKLAND.
ARE YOU AN UNARMED OFFICER OR
ARMED.
>> UNARMED.
>> Laura: SO YOUR ARMED OR
UNARMED, SORRY, I CAN’T HEAR.
>> NOT ARMED.
NO MA’AM.
WE ARE NOT ARMED.
>> Laura: WOULD YOU PREFER TO BE
ARMED OR YOU’RE NOT COMFORTABLE
WITH THAT?
>> I USED TO BE AN ARMED OFFICER
BEFORE I START WITH THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
ARMED WOULD BE BETTER I COULD DO
MORE BECAUSE IF THEY’RE SHOOTING
IN THE CAMPUS --
>> Laura: WHAT ARE YOU SUPPOSED
TO DO NOW WHEN SOMEONE GETS IN
THE BUILDING?
YOU PREVENTED A SCHOOL SHOOTING.
I’M GOING SAY IT.
PEOPLE SAY WELL, NO, YOU
PRESENTED A SCHOOL SHOOT.
WHAT WOULD HAVE HAPPENED TO THAT
KID WHO WE’RE NOT IDENTIFYING
BECAUSE HE’S A SNOWFLAKE, WHAT
ARE YOU SUPPOSED TO DO THROW
THINGS AT HIM?
WHAT THE HECK ARE YOU SUPPOSED
TO DO?
>> YOU DO WHAT THE FOOTBALL
COACH DID IN PARKLAND AND RUN AT
THE ARMED GUNMAN AND USE YOUR
OWN BODY AS ARMOR TO PROTECT
KIDS.
>> Laura: MARINO, THE TEACHERS
AND THE PARENTS AND FRANKLY THE
STUDENTS, IF THEY’RE NOT
INDOCTRINATED BY CNN OR OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS, SOMEONE LIKE YOU
WHO KNOWS HOW TO USE A FIREARM,
THE PRESIDENT SAID THAT TODAY,
PEOPLE WHO KNOW HOW TO USE
FIREARMS AND ADEPT SHOULD BE
ARMED AT A SCHOOL.
DO YOU AGREE WITH HIM?
>> I AGREE A LOT OF WITH HIM
BECAUSE  A LOT OF OFFICERS HAVE
TRAINING AND SHOULD BE STANDING
OUT SIDE AND SHOWING THE UNIFORM
SHOWING WE’RE NOT AN EASY
VICTIM.
WE’LL COME IN AND SHOOT BACK IF
YOU COME ON CAMPUS.
>> Laura: I WANT HIM ARMED.